spécialiste de la russie elena volochine
bonjour lna dans son discours dont qui a
duré onze minutes précisément vladmir
poutine a dit notamment que les
héritiers des vainqueurs sont les
défenseurs de la patrie aujourd'hui
c'est une inversion totale des rôles
comment est ce que vous avez aperçu ce
discours alors il faut noter
effectivement et vous avez raison de le
faire qu'avec ces célébrations né dans
une réalité absolument parallèle celle
dans laquelle vladimir poutine a plongé
les russes depuis l'invasion de
l'ukraine qui a commencé en 2014
aujourd'hui la russie est un pays en
guerre c'est un pays qui a agressé
l'état voisin c'est un pays qui compte
sans doute des milliers de morts dans un
conflit show actuelle sans qu'aucun
bilan officiel à jour 1 et été annoncée
y compris aujourd'hui par vladimir
poutine qui a dit que chaque soldat
tombé était une tragédie mais cela
resterait très théorique cela induit
qu'ils sont des que ce sont des cas
solitaire or on a là à moscou
aujourd'hui une ambiance de fête de
célébration de liesse populaire un
engouement un engouement total la guerre
est partout mais réellement elle n'est
nulle part elle est absolument théorique
et ce depuis le début avec ce qui est
présenté il faut le rappeler sur les
chaînes de télévision russes comme une
opération militaire spéciale visant à
des nazis fier l'ukraine et on ne voit
que des images de frappe satellite qui
soi-disant cible toujours des
infrastructures militaires et qui ne
font jamais ni de victimes civiles ni de
morts des deux côtés côté ukrainien
comme côté russe tout ceci participe à
la construction d'un mythe d'une russie
qui mènent une guerre noble juste une
guerre sacrée dans laquelle elle doit
absolument obtenir une victoire comme en
45 une guerre contre le nazisme le
bacille infections nationalistes comme
l'a dit des divas zimmer poutine juste
avant justement d'envahir l'ukraine est
une guerre dans laquelle il en va de la
survie de la russie on a du mal lna à
saisir le parallèle avec la seconde
guerre mondiale et le fait d'aller
défendre la patrie contre le nazisme
comme lorsque l'urss était en guerre aux
côtés des alliés contre contre hitler
oui et c'est tout à fait normal h rennes
parce que vladimir poutine il est dans
un prêche processus méthodique de
falsification de l'histoire depuis son
ascension au pouvoir en 2000 donc les
parallèles sont difficiles à saisir il
faut remonter pour cela à la source de
la falsification est pour cela notamment
je vais essayer de le faire grâce à ce
manuel officiel d'histoire russe des
classes de première les ramener ici il a
été réédité en 2021 lorsque l'histoire a
une nouvelle fois été réécrites encore
plus pour servir l'idéologie de vladimir
poutine et donc pour cela il faut aller
à la page du pacte de la signature du
pacte de non agression germano
soviétique molotov ribbentrop
on voit ici la photo donc deux ministres
russes des soviétiques des affaires
étrangères et staline signant ce pacte
c'est un sujet sensible n'est ce pas
pour l'urss et par extension pour la
russie qui se place dans cette
continuité historique et prétend
toujours avoir le beau rôle dans
l'histoire comme finalement l'aurait tu
staline conques ont redéfini aujourd'hui
en russie comme le héros comme le celui
qui a emmené l'armée soviétique vers la
victoire donc vous voyez déjà le
parallèle qui commence à se dessiner
avec être le fait d'être toujours du bon
côté de l'histoire pour ce qui est de la
russie alors le manuel prétend que
staline n'avait pas d'autre choix que de
signer ce pacte proposé par les
allemands parce que les français et les
britanniques auraient refusé de s'allier
avec lui contre hitler donc vous voyez
déjà c'est c'est la faute des
occidentaux finalement si staline a dû
signer ce pacte et c'est complètement
faux puisque jusqu'au bout les français
les britanniques ont tenté de négocier
avec staline qui a finalement privilégié
hitler concernant le partage de l'europe
et les protocoles secrets de ce pacte
molotov ribbentrop le manuel les
présentent comme la restauration d'une
injustice historique et le rendu à
l'urss de terre qui aurait dû être
historiquement celle de l'urss à l'issue
de la dislocation des empires après la
première guerre mondiale autrement dit
selon le manuel les frontières de
l'union aurait dû être celle de l'empiré
russe et vous voyez comment le parallèle
se précise encore plus avec ce discours
impérialistes prononcé par vladimir
poutine à la veille de la grande
offensive du 24 février où il a présenté
l'état ukrainien comme ayant été créée
par la russie qu'il n'avait pas
d'existence historique et que finalement
les vraies frontières de la russie
aurait être du bus aurait dû être celle
de l'urss mais dans les frontières de
l'empiré un discours impérieuse qui sert
donc à justifier l'invasion oui on l'a
vu et entendu aujourd'hui la patrie que
les russes doivent défendre ce n'est pas
la russie c'est l'urss donc l'urss au
sein de laquelle les nazis côté
ukrainien aurait pris du galon et que la
russie doit à les exterminer à tout prix
pour sauver ces territoires donc il ya
traditionnellement
lors de cette parade on l'a vu ces
symboles les drapeaux soviétiques sur la
place rouge ça ce n'est pas nouveau mais
il ya une nouveauté cette année au nom
de cette idéologie
par exemple la télévision russe a
renommé saint pétersbourg en leningrad
on n'a plus du tout entendu
saint-petersbourg il n'y avait que
leningrad dans les noms il est dans les
dents les scinder qui apparaissait à
l'écran donc c'est le nom soviétique un
de l'ancienne capitale de la russie
impériale on est en russie aujourd'hui
il faut le comprendre pour pour
comprendre cette réalité parallèle dans
un pays qui n'existe plus dans une
histoire qui a été réécrite dans une
propagande qui sert à justifier et
glorifié l'horreur absolue mais qui
n'apparaît pas comme une horreur aux
yeux des russes ce qui mène l'opération
d'agressions de l'ukraine sont présentés
comme des héros les valeureux héritiers
des vainqueurs qui mène une entreprise
noble qui défendent une cause sacrée et
le mot sacré est employé sans arrêt
celle d'aller libérer un pays de
lui-même finalement pour le rendre à la
russie comme lors du pacte
germano-soviétique l'urss de staline est
allé grâce de fait à l'alliance avec
hitler libérer les terres qui aurait dû
lui appartenir suite à la dislocation
des empires merci beaucoup et l'ena pour
sait